i know you don't like that legend
business i don't
why not marion because you are somewhat
of a legend you've been
doing this for a long time and you're
still there as founder and president
well because my daddy raised us and my
mother raised us to serve
and we are servant leaders
um and it is not about kind of external
things or labels
and i feel like the luckiest person in
the world have been born at the
intersection of great needs and great
injustices and great opportunities to
change them so
i just feel very grateful i could serve
and make a difference what a beautiful
way of saying it
[Music]
you grew up in the american south and
like
all children a lot of who you became
was molded by your parents
tell me what they what did they teach
you about movement building i had
extraordinary parents i was so lucky my
mother was the best organizer i ever
knew and she always insisted even back
then and having her own dime she started
her
her dairy so that she could have her
penny and that sense of independence has
certainly been passed on to me my daddy
was a minister and they were real
partners um and my
oldest sibling is a sister i'm the
youngest and there are three boys in
between
but i always knew i was as smart as my
brothers
i always was a tomboy um i always had
the same high aspirations that they had
but most importantly we were terribly
blessed
even though we were growing up in a very
segregated small town in south carolina
we knew it was wrong
i always knew from the time i was four
years old that i wasn't going to accept
being put into slots
but
daddy and mama always have this sense
that it was not us it's the outside
world but you have the capacity to grow
up to change it and i began to do that
very early on but most importantly they
were the best role models because they
said if you see a need don't ask why
somebody doesn't do it see what you can
do
there was no home for the agent in their
hometown and reverend reddick now has
what we knew no 50 years later had old
timers and he began to wander the
streets and so
daddy and mama figured out he needed a
place to go so we started home for the
ages children had to cook and clean and
serve we didn't like it at the time
but that's how we learned that it was
our obligation to take care of those who
couldn't take care of themselves
i had
12 foster sisters and brothers
my mother took them in after we left
home but she took them on before we left
home
and again whenever you see a need you
try to fulfill it god runs daddy used to
say a full employment economy
and so that if you just follow the need
you will never lack for something to do
or a real purpose in life and every
issue that the children's defense fund
works on today comes out of my childhood
um in a very personal way little johnny
harrington who lived three
doors down from me stepped on a nail
live with his grandmother got tetanus
into the hospital no tetanus shots he
died
he was 11 years old i remember that an
accident in front of our highway
turns out to have been a white two white
truck drivers
um and a migrant family that happened to
be black we all ran out to help if it's
in the front of the church and the
ambulance came
saw that the white truck drivers were
not injured
so the black migrant workers were
turned around and left them i never
forgot that and immunizations was one of
the first things i worked on at the
children's defense fund to make sure
that every child gets immunized against
preventable diseases
um
unequal schools
and evil schools
separate and unequal hand me downs from
the white schools that we always had
books in our house daddy was a great
reader he should make me read every
night with him i'd have to sit for 15 to
20 minutes one day i put a true
confessions inside a life magazine and
he asked me
to read it out loud i never read her
true confessions again
it was them but they were great readers
we always had books before we had a
second pair of shoes and that was very
important and although we had
hand-me-down books for the black schools
and hand-me-down everything's um it was
a great need
he made it clear that reading was kind
of the window to the outside world and
so that was a great gift from them
um and but
he the the reinforced lesson was that
god runs a full employment economy
and that if you just follow the need
you'll never lack for a purpose in life
and that has been so for me we had a
very segregated small town i was a rebel
from the time i was four or five i went
up to a department store and
there was white and black water signs
but i didn't know that and didn't pay
much attention to that and i was with
one of my sunday school teachers and i
drank out of the wrong water fountain
and she jerked me away and i didn't know
what had happened and then she explained
to me about black and white water i
didn't know that but i would go in after
that i went home took my little wounded
psyche to my parents and told him what
had happened and said what's wrong with
me um and they said it wasn't what's
wrong with you is wrong with with the
system and i used to go then secretly
and switch water signs everywhere i went
and it felt so good
but there is
there is no question that this legend is
a bit of a rebel right it has been for a
long time
so you started your work as an attorney
and with the civil rights movement and
you worked with dr king and the original
poor people's campaign and then you made
this decision 45 years ago to set up a
national advocacy campaign for children
why did you choose that particular
service to children well because so many
of the things that
i saw in mississippi and across south
um had to do with children i saw
children with bloated bellies in this
country who were close to starvation who
were hungry who were without clothes
and nobody wanted to believe that they
were children who
were starving and that's a slow process
um and nobody wanted to listen every
congressman that come to mississippi i'd
say go see and most of them didn't want
to do anything about it um but i saw
grinding poverty the state of
mississippi wanted doing voter
registration efforts and with outside
white kids coming in to help black
citizens register to vote
they want everybody to leave the state
so they were trying to starve them out
and they switched from
free food commodities that to food
stamps that cost two dollars people had
no income and nobody in america wanted
to believe that there was anybody in
america without any income well i knew
hundreds of them thousands of them and
malnutritions are becoming a big problem
and so one of these days came dr king
down on a number of things we were
fighting to get the head start program
which the state of mississippi turned
down re-refinanced
and he went into a
center that the poor community was
running without any help
and he saw a teacher carve up an apple
for eight or ten children and he had to
run out because he was in tears he
couldn't believe it but only when robert
kennedy decided he would come
i had gone to testify about the head
start program as they were attacking
when i asked please come and see
yourself when you come and see see
hungry people and see starving children
and they came and he brought the press
and that began to get the movement going
but they wanted to push all these people
of the poor people to go north and to
get away from
being voters and i'm proud of mike pepsi
even though he lost last night he'll win
one of these days
um and
but it was you know it was
you wouldn't have seen such grinding
poverty and the outside white kids would
come in to help register votes voters in
the 1964 summer project where we lost
those three young men
but once they left
the press left
and there was this massive need and
people were trying to push the poor out
and so you know
head start came and we applied for it
because the state turned it down and
that's true of a lot of states don't
take medicaid these days um and we ran
the largest head start program in the
nation and it changed their lives they
had books that had
children look like them in it and we
were attacked all over the place but the
bottom line was that mississippi
gave birth to the children's defense
fund in many ways
and it also occurred to me that children
and preventive investment and avoiding
costly care and failure and neglect um
was a more strategic way to proceed
and so the children's defense fund was
born out of the poor people's campaign
but it was pretty clear that whatever
you call black independent or brown
independent was going to have a
shrinking constituency and who can be
mad at a two-month-old baby or at a
two-year-old toddler a lot of people can
be and they don't want to feed them
either i mean we've seen but it was the
right judgment to make and so out of the
privilege of serving as the poor
people's campaign coordinator for policy
um for two years and there were two of
them and it was not a failure because
the seeds have changed
you know get planted and have to have
people who are scut workers and follow
up and i'm a good gut worker and a
persistent person
um and you know as a result i would say
there are all these people on food
stamps today ought to thank those four
people in the mud and resurrection city
but it takes a lot of follow-up detailed
work and never going away and you've
been doing it for 45 years and you've
seen some amazing outcomes
what what are you proud of stuff out of
the children's defense fund
well i think the children now are sort
of become a mainstream issue
we have got
lots of new laws
millions of children are getting
food millions of children are getting a
head start millions of children are
getting head start and and
have gotten a head start and
the child health insurance program chip
medicaid expansions for children we've
been trying to reform the child welfare
system for decades we finally got a big
breakthrough this year and it says be
ready with the proposals when somebody
is ready to move and sometimes it takes
five years 10 years 20 years but you're
there i've been trying to keep children
out of foster care and out of
institutions and with their families
with preventive services that got passed
but there are millions of children who
have hope who have access to early
childhood now we are not finished and we
are not going to ever feel finished
until we end child poverty in the
richest nation on earth it's just
ridiculous that we have to be demanding
that
[Applause]
and there are so many of the problems in
spite of the successes and thank you for
going through some of them uh marian the
the freedom schools the generations of
children now who have gone through
children's defense fund programs but
when you look around the world in in in
this country in the united states and in
other countries there are still so many
problems what worries you the most
what worries me is how irresponsible we
adults in power have been in passing on
a healthier earth
and i it worries me when i read the
bulletin of atomic scientists and see
now that we're two minutes from midnight
and that's gotten closer we have
put our future and our children's future
and safety at risk
um in a world that is
still too much governed by violence we
must end that we must stop investing in
war and start investing in the young and
in peace and we are really so far away
from doing that
and i
don't want my grandchildren
to have to fight these battles all over
again and so i get more radical the
older i get the more radical i get
because there's just some things that we
as adults have to do for the next
generations and i looked at the
sacrifices of mrs hamers and all those
people in mississippi who risked their
lives that they have given us a better
life but the united states has got to
come to grips with its failure to invest
in its children is that it's the
achilles heel of this nation how can you
be one of the biggest economies in the
world and you let 13.2 million children
go live in poverty and you let children
go homeless when you've got the means to
do it we've got to rethink who we are as
a people
be an example for the world there should
be no poverty in fact we have we want to
say we're going to end poverty in the
world and let's start at home and we've
made real progress but it's such hard
work and it's going to be our achilles
heel we should stop
giving more tax cuts sorry folks to
billionaires rather than to babies and
their healthcare you should get our
priorities straight
that's not right and it's not cost
effective and the key to this country is
going to be an educated child population
and yet we've got so many children who
cannot read or write at the most basic
levels we're investing in the wrong
things and i wouldn't be upset about
anybody having 1 billion 10 billion
if there were no hungary children if
there were no homeless children if there
were no uneducated children and so it's
really about what does it mean to live
and and and live
this life why are we put on this earth
we put on this earth to to make things
better for the next generations and here
we're worrying about climate change and
global warming and we're looking at that
again i constantly cite that that i look
at that of atomic scientists
every year and said now two minutes to
midnight are we out of our minds adults
about passing on a better world or world
to our children that's what our purpose
is is to leave a better world for
everybody and the concept of enough for
everybody there should be no hungry
children in this world with the rich
wealth that we have and so i can't think
of a bigger cause
and i think that i'm driven by my faith
um and it's been a privilege to serve
but i always had the best role models in
the world
daddy always said god runs a full
employment economy
and that if you just follow the need
you'll never lack for a purpose in life
and i watched the partnership because my
mother was a true partner i always knew
i was as smart as my brothers at least
and we always knew that we were not just
to be about ourselves but that we were
here to serve
well mary and i want to say on behalf of
all the world's children thank you for
your passion
your purpose and your advocacy
[Applause]
[Music]